continuing where we left off last week
with regards to understanding the decree
of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
we mentioned for the decree of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala there are four
levels we mentioned
three of those levels and today
tonight's insha allah we are going to
conclude
with the fourth and final of these four
levels
so when we say belief in allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
we mean a particular thing when the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was asked
when jibreel asked him tell me about
iman what is it
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said that you believe in allah
there's a very particular meaning to
that
belief in allah
it's not just belief in his existence
it's not just belief that allah is the
only creator
this is not this is not what was
intended
by this statement when he said belief in
allah
it entailed that and much more
right he says belief
in that you believe in allah
that you believe in the angels
and the revelations and the messengers
and the
day of resurrection and that you believe
in
decree the good of it and the bad of it
a very specific thing there was intended
for
there's an addition to this narration
that you believe in
the decree the good of it the bad of it
the sweet of it and the sour of it that
addition of sweet and sour
is an addition which is inauthentic
it did not come from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam however
its meaning is correct because some
things that happens to us
we would describe them as being very
sour and some things that happen we
would describe them as being very
sweet however
it's a very important principle that i'd
to articulate tonight
take this principle into mind
take it into your heart hold it
understand it
[Silence]
this is a very important principle
and that is that not every
statement which is true or correct
or good or tasteful
or well worded is
good enough to be the words of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam the words of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam they have
very specific
conditions for us to ascribe it to the
prophet muhammad
some narrations are clearly
false wrong other narrations
their meanings are very correct and
accurate but they're inauthentic
the statement itself may be true but it
doesn't mean that it's the statement of
the prophet muhammad
[Silence]
the
and so there are
narrations which are authentic
there are narrations which are
acceptable
there are narrations which are weak
and there are narrations which are lies
they are categorically
incorrect and
we had mentioned and i had promised to
mention one narration
and this goes back to the second level
of al-qaeda
but i didn't have a cha i forgot last
week it slipped my mind to mention it
which it would have been more
appropriate to mention it during the
second part which is el kitaba
narration that is floating around
that is positively in incorrect
and is a fabrication against the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and its meaning is incorrect too
i mean some narrations and this is not
for everyone this is only for the
scholars of hadith
certain narrations they may see it and
immediately know that this could not be
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
words
be this is for the scholars of hadith
this is not for tom dick and harry
every one of us to pick up a book and
then sit here and flip through it a
novel
and start to say that sounds good and
that sounds kind of fishy and that
sounds kind of weird to me
le this is very dangerous and this has
become
a common theme lately
no what we're talking about are the
scholars of hadith who have the
authority
to discuss the authenticity of the words
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
as opposed to the inauthentic words that
are not his
and so in one of these narrations
i'll mention it in arabic and then i'll
translate it
i want to preface this very much that
this narration is
inauthentic it is not an authentic
narration as a matter of fact it is
positively a lie
from a shaitaan and
[Silence]
is
foreign
[Silence]
be
foreign
[Silence]
and so in this narration this is a
fabricated narration
it's mentioned that jibreel
saw that there was a man who was very
fervent in his worship of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and that this man was constantly praying
and fasting and he was so devout
so jibreel
asked permission from allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to look at the preserved tablet
to see if this man was going to be of
the people of paradise
automatically from this statement alone
we know that this narration is a
fabrication
because the preserved tablet is
something that only allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is privy to
[Arabic recitation]
so as the story goes and the story is
false
it is not a true story that jibril went
and found that this man was
condemned to hell in the preserved
tablet
meaning in his future he was hell-bound
and so he asked permission to go and
tell this man
and allah wa ta'ala allegedly gave him
permission so jibreel went to the man
and said look you're working really hard
you're praying
and you're fasting and you're doing all
this stuff
you should just enjoy your life while
you still
are alive because i looked into the
preserved tablets and you're supposed to
go to hell anyways
so all of this is for nothing
so jibril is basically encouraging
this man to go and
be a criminal with the rest of his life
because what's the point anyways
so this man he said well if that's what
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has condemned
me to then it is his choice
and he went back and did not change his
worship of allah in any way
and so jibreel allegedly allegedly this
is a fake narration this is not
real it shows you the difference between
a real narration and a fake narration
went back to the preserved tablet and
found that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala had
changed it to
that this man would be of the people of
paradise
right this narration is clearly a
fabrication
for many many reasons
but one of the main reasons is that
this individual his
outcome in the hereafter was changed in
the preserved
tablet
it is referred to in the quran as
preserved meaning nothing changes in it
it's preserved
if we keep changing things in it what
why would we call it the preserved
tablet
and so the point of this statement
is that the statement of allah
that allah erases what he chooses
and affirms what he chooses and with him
resides the mother and the reference of
all of the book
this is a reference to anes
meaning that allah may change one ruling
and replace it with another ruling that
is more
appropriate for the time and place
etcetera and nasa
abrogation translated to abrogation in
english
now i mentioned this story now it's a
little bit late in the game because
we're way past where this story would
have been relevant
but i was reminded to mention it so
there it is
the fabricated narrations are many
many many fabricated narrations
they are by the thousands
right and none of them are contained in
bukhari a muslim
none of them are contained in the six
books of hadith
none of them are contained in malik or
muslim
ahmed none of them are contained in
these famous
well-known books of the scholars of
hadith
these narrations which are fabrications
are found in very obscure
books and works of
i want to make that clear because we
have this new wave now we have this new
agenda which is
people will read a book of hadith
and start to pick and choose and decide
that that narration sounds really weird
to me i don't think that's authentic
as if the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is something
that is open to debate
and as if scholarship of almost 1500
years
15 centuries has not already dealt with
these
issues and hashed them out
it's very important that we take this
into consideration because
this is this is
one of the
more disturbing trends that are
happening with the younger
generations today and even the older
generations as well
you have certain people
right now
or the whatever he is gets on the
national television in egypt or in
jordan or
in any other country and starts to
dissect narrations of sahih al-bukhari
or
muslim and try to prove that these are
fabricated narrations
these people are criminals and the
people that put them up are criminals as
well
these narrations are not have not
been placed there by
fools and they have not been preserved
by fools these p
these people these scholars of
[Silence]
these individuals specialized in the
science of hadith and they specialized
in the science of hadith so much so
that they could dissect the narration
and know it
know the narrations of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam just you
and i know
our own names right if i were to say to
you right now
what would happen everybody would raise
his hand and say wait
you missed a verse correct
you missed that this is how they this is
this is the depth of their knowledge
with regards to the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
so the books of hadith are sacred
they are not open for debate
they are not something that have been
misplaced
and mishandled and just opened for
anybody to play around with
the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
has guardians from the very very very
beginning
from the first word he spoke as a
prophet
what was the first word he spoke as a
[Silence]
he said i don't know how to read.
the highest of companionship
meaning that this was his choice just to
remain in this earth or to go to the
higher
companionship of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
so we have from the very beginning in
the middle of the desert
in a cave by himself until the last word
he ever spoke
all of that which is in between has been
preserved by the companions of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
meticulously with extreme
attention to detail so much so that a
letter
a single letter cannot make its way into
a hadith
without it being noticed so this is
something that
is a little bit off topic but it is a
trend that i'm
seeing a lot of today
people will pick up the muslims
muslim men and muslim women
and one of the main reasons for this
is that they have been conditioned
to look for certain things and reject
certain things
right so we are taught in our society
that men should be a particular way
women should be a particular way
this meaning is wrong this meaning is
correct
and and then we look into the sunnah of
the prophet
alaihi and we see that there's
contradictions with what we've been
taught in movies
and media and what we've been inoculated
with
and so we start to try to harmonize
and when we have that cognitive
dissonance occur
we start to disregard parts of the sun
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
this is extremely dangerous
and the correct opinion
that even allah wrote an entire book
that there is not a single narration in
muslim
imam ahmed which is fabricated
its conditions are much much much
more lenient than books sahih
al-bukhari
muslim these are books that are
untouchable
they are beyond reproach right
and this goes back to what we mentioned
before and that is the way of the
scholars
the way of a a true scholar is
when you do not understand something you
say amen
we believe in it all of it has come to
us from our lord.
[Silence]
so last week we discussed the third
level of the third level of
the decree of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
we said the first level is
the second level
we discussed that in depth
the third level
that allah knew
all that is to be wrote all of that in
the preserved tablet
and that willed for all of that
which was written in the preserved
tablet to be
he willed it subhanahu
the fourth which we will discuss today
is
is creation that
after he willed for it to be he created
it subhanahu wata'ala he brought it into
existence
and kept it in existence
right that is
as allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has said
allah
has created everything
meaning everything that is created it's
been created by allah wa'ta'ala
whether it is good or it is bad
whether it is good or pure or it is evil
everything has been created by allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
there is nothing that is a creation
that has been created by other than
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
but here is where we're going to discuss
the difference between
the beliefs of sunnah
and the beliefs of with regards to this
issue
some people will say well what are you
trying to say are you saying that allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala created
evil too that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
created evil
he created zinna he created murder he
created
any of these things and all of these
things are creations of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
yet the difference is not
in whether or not he created these
things or not
rather it is why he has created these
things
[Silence]
there is a difference between allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's legislative will
what he desires
and there is a difference between allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's
what is actually happening and what he
wills to occur
for a wisdom and i'll give an example of
that
the scholars of islam they refer to this
as hobbus
he for example
if we take two things here
let's say we take
a glass of cold water and
a tablet of aspirin okay
a glass of cold water a tablet of
aspirin
a glass of cold water is enjoyable in
itself
we will drink the water not just because
it keeps us alive but because
it in itself is tasty and good and
nourishing and we love it itself
it itself is the ends it's the means and
the ends
correct
now when we look at something like
aspirin
which is taken originally from the aspen
tree it is notorious for being
one of the most bitter things you could
ever taste
right aspirin is extremely bitter
it doesn't taste good it's very
unpleasant to take
it causes acid in the stomach it causes
ulcers if a person takes it too much it
thins the blood
it does all of these things right
all of these adverse effects to aspirin
but we still produce aspirin
don't we we produce it as human beings
and we buy it and we take it all the
time
why because when you have a headache
it alleviates your headache
or whatever other reason a person may
take it for fever or for
whatever so we don't love the aspirin
itself we don't love it in the same way
that we love the cold water
we love it because the results that come
about can only come about through that
bitterness
correct this is the difference between
good and evil in the creation of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala creates good
for good sake
simply because it is good but
in this world evil is created for what
reason
because there is some wisdom that
some some effect that can only come
about by way of
this evil thing
for example
he wrote a book on iblis one of his
treaties
on iblis
and he mentioned more than 20 benefits
for the existence of iblees
[Silence]
there is a narration collected by a
deremi
and hadith
[Arabic recitation]
desire that evil exist
on this earth he would not have created
iblis in the first place
he is the one who created iblis
but because people will disobey him
because people will go against his will
because he he has given the human being
that choice now
between
iblis now is either a propelling force
for good
even though he doesn't want to be and
he's not trying to be
so the point here is that there are two
different types of wills
there is a will i will that allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala wills this thing
for itself and the other is that allah
will something for
some reason that may come along and that
is the meaning of
that you believe in the decree of allah
the good of it
and the bad of it the good of it like
what like
healthy children and health and
smiles and good times and whatever it is
right and the bad of it is what
volcanoes and hurricanes and and war
and murder and all of these things that
are bad
these are all parts of the bad
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was speaking of
when he was speaking of belief in a
belief in the decree of allah the good
of it
and the bad of it now
it's very important for us to understand
that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala creates
good
and wills good for good sake
and that evil is something which is
created for
some wisdom that comes from behind it
one of the best examples of this that
allah explains this to us
as much as we can understand
is the story of al-khador and musa
if we look at the story of al khadr and
musa salaam in surah
we see that al khadr
represents he is symbolic
of the seemingly senseless
chaos that happens in the earth
right he's symbolic of that
and that muslim is symbolic of
the human being trying to understand
that chaos
so anaz
[Silence]
if we look at the first story of
that as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentioned in the narration of
ibn abbas which is collected by
imam al-bukhari that
al-khabar and musa went along and they
rode on a ship
and the people of this ship were very
nice to them
and they let them ride for free because
they happened to know al-qaeda
what did the do when he got out into the
ship
he put a hole in it right
why would you do that why is it that
people that are being nice to us you
would
go and do something that to them
we have the second story and that is
that
the story of the child
that al-khadur killed
he finds this innocent child and this
innocent child is killed and put to
death
why would you do something that
this seems chaotic
it doesn't seem it is something
which is
which is in line with the wisdom of
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
or the will of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and we have in the third story they go
to a village
the people of the village are very rude
to them they
push them out and what does do
he builds a part of their village for
free
right
a
so if we look at these stories we see
that
it's as if those who are nice to us we
reward that niceness with
evil and those who are evil to us we
reward that evil with good
but when when it is explained to us
later
then we understand right
we understand that the hole in the ship
that lo that hole had to be made to save
the whole ship
otherwise they would have lost
everything
and we understand that that child that
was so dear to their parents
to his parents that child had he grown
up would
he and he would have been
he would have gone to hell and taken his
parents with him
right and we see that
in the third story the people that were
evil and rude to them
he actually covered something
from them being able to get to it
that otherwise wouldn't have been
covered now as we said
is a real person and musa
is a real person but these stories
symbolizes the legislation of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and what happens in the earth and what
seems to be very
chaotic but there is a very very deep
reason behind it
and for this reason the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam commented and
said
he said may allah have mercy on musa if
he would have been a little bit more
patient
we would have learned a lot more we
would have learned a lot more from
al-khadr and so
certain things that happen to you in
your life
i mean how do we if we look at this now
and we say how do i apply this to my
life how do you apply this to your life
right certain things that you see to be
painful in your life
if you knew what was really happening
and if you had true trust in allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala you would choose it
for
to be no other way you might do it to
yourself
just the people of that boat had
they known that their boats would have
been seized
if it was if it was
unharmed they would have put the hole in
the boat themselves
they themselves would have done it had
they known but they didn't know
right and so
the point here is that when a person
accepts
the decree of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he accepts it not because he knows it
or because he understands it but he
accepts the decree of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala because it is the decree of
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and that allah chooses for the person
what is best
for him not necessarily what he wants
not necessarily what he wants
an arrow will only become an arrow with
friction
you have to grind it that's the only way
to make it sharp enough
to do its job it's unpleasant
it's not fun i'd rather be doing
other things but that is the way that
our world works
the way that our world works it's it's a
place of friction
right the more friction there is
the more progress there is the less
friction
there is the less progress there is
and that's why we see in times of war
for example
statistically statistically speaking
when we look at things war we find
that the greatest
inventions that make our lives easiest
happen during war
that's when they were made and certain
discoveries
if you look at something that every
single one of us has probably taken in
his life and has saved his life
something penicillin right
penicillin which is
an antibiotic how was this discovered it
was discovered during war
because people were getting shot in
their toe and die die from it
from infection and so this propelled
a lot of progress this is how progress
is made in our
and our world here
these are the four levels of decree of
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala if we
understand these four levels of decree
then to a degree we will understand
what is meant by
to believe and decree the good of it and
the bad of it
we understand now what that means and
what is intended by that
inshallah we will continue next week
it's difficult life is difficult
everybody has
his struggles in his life
but it's important for us as believers
to understand that
what allah decrees for us
is better for us than what we would
choose for our own selves
and this is the thamara this is one of
the many fruits reaped
by the person who believes in the decree
of allah subhanahu
foreign